[Music]
no one crushes a throwback moment like a
kardashian and kim kardashian just
shared the throwback to end all
throwbacks thank you
on thursday the 40 year old's reality
star posted a rare home video to
instagram featuring her older sister
courtney and her younger sister chloe
lip-synching to tiffany's 1987 track i
think we're alone now
[Music]
i don't know what i love most the shiny
90s outfits the giant hair bows the
passionate lip sync performance it's
just all so good
why not
but honestly i think it's chloe front
and center in those shades for me
[Music]
kim captioned the clip quote our star
search audition clearly we didn't get
four stars but kris jenner did for our
outfits
yeah they may not have made it on the
hit talent competition show but these
ladies were clearly destined for fame
something kim knew early on does
everyone get a tape of this because i
hope you do so you can see me when i'm
famous and all do you remember me okay
i'm this beautiful little girl
just check out this exclusive home video
from the et vault it's the kkw beauty
founder at her eighth grade graduation
in 1994.
my name is kim kardashian i'm the dopest
and the ropest person in this class
i'm dope in a row yeah even as a
teenager kim knew a thing or two about
being cool i'm the dopest and the ropest
person in this class
i'm dope in a row the beauty mogul seems
to be taking a lot of trips down memory
lane these days last week she posted
this vintage snap from a college party
when court was a student at the
university of arizona in the caption she
revealed university of arizona
single-handedly stopped me from turning
into a wild party girl i remember
visiting court on campus and being her
designated driver kim said that she
hated all of the wild parties so much
that she quote stayed home and never
wanted to drink or party ever but
courtney remembered the night a little
differently and reposted kim's pick to
her insta story writing quote i remember
feeding you jungle juice and someone
else driving i won't name names and
blasting rough riders maybe i was
partying too hard to remember correctly
anyone else who was there want to chime
in yes
still kim stuck to her story writing um
not me i remember 14 people squeezing
into our car i was driving or was it
khloe kardashian blasting eminem bar
fight broken jaw that's about it for
this weekend in a z
so whether it's an epic college story or
a 90's lip syncing moment
no one does a throwback quite like kim
yes
[Music]